mercedes-benz's maybach s600 is speaking
past the competition the starting price
of this vehicle is two hundred thirty
thousand dollars Chinese buyers are
snapping up about 500 of these vehicles
a month and Pimm Fox has been tracking
all of this Pam does this car proved
that the luxury market in china isn't
exactly slowing down for everyone well
for the right product people will come
out and and partake in the conspicuous
consumption if you're looking for a
silver-plated champagne flutes or
goblets or if you're looking for extra
legroom the new Maybach as you said
doing very well selling about 500 a
month it used to sell about 600 a year
but this is all part of a strategy by
mercedes to rebrand maibock as part of a
Mercedes company not a separate company
and it really has to do more with the
change in the nature of the competition
at the high end of the automobile market
audi is feeling the pinch Mercedes is
feeling it and you're also seeing it
with companies like Porsche they're
selling more of the lower priced
McCann's than they are selling the
higher price cayenne so that's just a
change it and how they frame it yes and
how they change it and how they take
your money still